tennislegende boris becker in london
nicht wir wollten nicht centre court
sondern vor gericht im
insolvenzverfahren soll er
vermögenswerte verschwiegen haben dass
kann ihn teuer zu stehen kommen bis zu
sieben jahre haft drohen die richterin
ist gnadenlos überlegte fußfessel und
hohe kaution wegen fluchtgefahr
immerhin musste er seinen pass abgeben
die nächste anhörung ist ende oktober
becker selbst beteuert seine unschuld in
allen neun zehn anklagepunkten da ist
wieder eine menge los traurig dass er
kaum zu sagen ja an schraube der arme
mann wie mir so ein ist will ich jetzt
durchaus richtig weil ich denke mir wenn
eine über 50 ist er heißt nicht becker
herr becker sondern der heißt der boris
ja wie die über 50 jahren dass darüber
muss man mal nachdenken
ich sage angelo oder der kristianstad
christian lindner sagte vdr merkel und
so weiter das ist der boris ja dann wird
immer irgendwie in unserem bewusstsein
ein heranwachsender sein also er tut mir
leid obwohl er zu mir nie sehr nett war
ja hat einmal zu seiner damaligen frau
waage sagt barbara überlegte mit wem du
befreundet bist direkte die eliminieren
ich da rede ich mit dem verleger und
dann ist die frau weg ja also ich war
nicht weg er hat ihn das erzählt hat
dass bad bibra direkt ja ja das habe ich
von mehreren seiten gehört aber später
ich bin mir oft sehr oft begegnet und
einer weise wird er immer wird er immer
ein idol sein ja der mann der junge mann
der wimmeln gewonnen hat der typ der
immer kämpft und selbst wenn man denkt
dieses tennis spiel ist vorbei
dann steht noch einmal auf kämpft das
finde ich wirklich bemerkenswert und den
wird für millionen menschen wird er ein
idol sein ja und ich habe auch auf
twitter und auf den in den sozialen
medien gelesen wie viele sagen lasst
doch den armen mann in ruhe auf der
anderen seite das was er gemacht hat ist
kriminell er hat einfach einen großteil
von von nicht großteil also einige
immobilien gelder hat er wahrscheinlich
irgendwo noch versäumt und
ist das wichtig geworden war eigentlich
ja noch nein ich hatte ein bisschen was
versäumt und sagt es habe ich irgendwie
vergessen ja aber er will ja nicht vor
gericht stehen wenn die haben die dinge
ja gefunden ja und er sagt nun ja das
werde ich irgendwie so erklären und ich
glaube sein naturell ist oder so sagt
ich bin der boris becker ich komme da
raus auf alle fälle er
und im übrigen glaube ich auch dass er
irgendwie raus kommt und ja er mir auch
überhaupt nicht leid finger er das
eigene selbstbewusstsein auf die füße
gefallen und ich finde das sieht man
auch zum beispiel daran dass er nichts
besseres zu tun hatte als bei dem ersten
gerichtstermin danach in scotts in
mayfair erstmal essen gewann der
angebliche heute ist und aber nur
insolvenzverfahren wirklich
schwierigkeiten hat setzt sich danach
erstmal hin und sagt so jetzt gibt es
aber erstmal hier beim der bayernliga
feinfühligen eine gewisse ist mir egal
wer ist selbstbewusst wie donald trump
leute was wollt ihr von mir ich bin der
boris becker ich weiß wie es geht wenn
wir übrigens moderiert und und
tennisspieler erklärt das macht er
fantastisch und und er ist hat also als
persönlichkeit eine totale präsenz ja
und wenn der innenraum reinkommt dann
ist der raum voll das muss ich wirklich
sagen obwohl ich nicht seine freundin
wenn ja also das tut mir ein bisschen
leid weil ich glaube dass es in
irgendeinem teil eine lebenserfahrung
fehlt dem wir alle anderen hatten ja wir
haben irgendwie gearbeitet wir haben uns
ein partie ja das ist doch gar nicht so
schlecht oder empathie oder das gefühl
man muss sich anpassen man muss sich an
regeln halten
es gibt regeln die für uns alle gelten
ja aber ich glaube boris becker ist der
meinung der steht weit drüber das ja
aber auch neben dem motto der partie
haben im harz ist natürlich wenig
gemeinsam ja und wie diskutiert mal mit
einem narzissten am besten gar nichts
mit lang mit ihm genau das will ich noch
mal darauf zurückgehen gute frage ich
habe nicht mitleid mit ihm was
abwasser angeblich gemacht haben ja dann
irgendwas muss er da dran sein das ist
natürlich doof ob er das macht oder
heinz müller von nebenan das macht man
nicht es gibt gesetze und die analyse
hat man sich zu halten
aber was ich so hart findet jetzt wie
das jetzt obwohl es nicht fix ist er so
dermaßen gehetzt wird und gejagt wird
und das glaube ich muss also ich glaube
dass hier ein gegner steht also der ja
auch der braucht scheinwerfer und ich
meine das mag ja das ist ja das sind ja
ja das ja ohne scheinwerfer ich bin weil
ich gesehen werde
ja man darf auch nicht vergessen boris
becker war der mann der gesagt hat als
seine tochter auf die welt kommt das
samenraub ich meine wie kann man sich
dass das meine mutter ist aus denken ja
aber wie gesagt das hat er gerne aber
dann kann er ihnen doch auch nicht
leitung mit oder im übrigen kein
bisschen leider doch wer also ich weine
sind zudem mir leid warum also es geht
ihm blenden er hat offenbar nehme ich
mal an noch genug geld das ein
wunderbares leben in london führen kann
ja ich offenbar eventuell ein paar
fehler gemacht die werden jetzt
verhandeln die treffen ihn aber nicht so
wahnsinnig im kern dass sie sich da
offenbar wahnsinnig große sorgen darüber
macht aber ich hab das gefühl boris
becker meckert die ganze zeit über sie
wahrnehmen über die wahrnehmung der von
außen wahrgenommen wird ich muss nach
london ziehen die deutschen erkennen
mich nicht mehr genug an valentin an
nein ich glaube dass ich glaube auch
legt daher konnten die den knast nein es
ist ich glaube das wird sich noch jahre
so ein insolvenzverfahren ist irrsinnig
kompliziert da gibt es sicherlich noch
so ein paar türen ich will auch da
einfach kann eine bewertung machen was
er da und wie es heißt er konnten
verschwiegen es geht um 1,5 millionen
also das sind schon in städtischen
wohnungen aber und sein scheint ja
irgend ein bewunderer von innen und hat
noch viele und er sagt okay was kostet
das ja dafür musst du dann halt meinen
kindern tennisunterricht geben oder nach
sonstwohin stehen da gefahren andere
nicht leid tun also wo jan wird mir
schon leid weil ihm fehlt einfach eine
erfahrung eine lebensspanne die wir alle
hatten er ist aber mitleid das ist also
das ist nicht so der arme wird gehetzt
wird schon materiell sondern damit auch
der arme ist geht er fasst er in dem
bereich der arme bobbele der hat aber
einen entscheidenden aspekt und seinen
liga verpasst habe ich schon mitleid mit
menschen denen
einfach reden die meist hält die
lebensweisheit das gefällt mir gut ja
dass das fehlt eben ja und es wird auch
nie haben ja aber wie gesagt es ist
strotzt vor selbstbewusstsein und die
demut fehlt
[Musik]